historically building a website has made
me want to do this without any coding
experience I either end up drowning in
the sea of HTML tags or stuck with some
super cheesy template but over the last
week I've discovered that building a
beautiful modern web site is now
insanely easy far easier than raising a
13 week old puppy neat browser yes I
named my puppy browser as in web browser
and then naturally I decided to make him
a beautiful website I know what you're
thinking that sounds very 1995 of you
but all the fleeting photos I post on
Twitter Instagram or Facebook don't feel
very personal or permanent so we tested
for build your own website tools and
within an hour of using each of them I
was able to build some pretty great
looking site no code or HTML required so
you're probably not building a site for
your brand new puppy but these tools can
be used for your own personal or
business site here's how we did it the
first step is deciding what service you
want to build your site web
I recommend Weebly or Squarespace both
were easy to use and let you create very
attractive pages but each service offers
something that the other doesn't we
believe for instance has a more
intuitive interface and drag and drop
features while Squarespace has much
better looking templates and designs you
can try both for free to see which one
you like best we decided to go with
Squarespace for browser in your browser
com
I just was really impressed with all the
tools they give you to start building
the entire build process happens in the
browser you select the template and then
start customizing and adding to it I got
all the photos and text in one place
then customized it more by adding
browsers Instagram feed and a forum
where you can ask questions the hardest
part of building the site was actually
just gathering all the photos and videos
and writing the text what's great about
both services is that they both have
mobile tools both have iOS and Android
apps for updating your sites on the road
plus you can see what the mobile view of
your own website looks like right
through the web app when your site is
ready for the world you can set it live
with a new or old domain both Weebly and
Squarespace sell domains directly
Squarespace charge $20 for the domain
including private registry
which keeps your name and address hidden
Squarespace then charges a minimum of $8
a month
Weebly charged $40 for the domain for
the year plus an extra 10 to keep your
info private that includes access to
Weebly services but if you don't buy
your domain through Weebly it's just
four dollars a month to use your own
domain it's so easy he's falling asleep
on the job but seriously it's amazing
what a great looking website you can
make now with no programming experience
and just a little bit of time now one of
these companies could just make dog
training that easy